also I want to say out of all the white
dudes I know man
like I let you you you were very funny
number one but I loved it I let you get
real racial with me yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's because you know me why well I
just feel like there is a relationship
that we have that we understand that I'm
I'm superior to you race wise and you
know that yeah maybe deep down inside I
do you do yeah and you let it happen
because the white man wins again we
should always win and we are always
gonna win yeah
white power race war though let's
suppose this is a race war I think you'd
probably won the first white people to
die no no no you know cuz I work out I'm
athletic I wasn't mad I would do pretty
well you people can see you in a sniper
Spokeo if you're [ __ ] stupid ready
yeah yeah look at the red hair and shoot
up gear to the record yeah but um no if
a race war broke out I would call up all
my black friends I would call up all the
black people that I've ever known
and say can you adopt me can I be on
your team really I'll sell out anything
I'll sell out anybody I'll do anything
would you blow in a race war what I blow
a guy to live a black eye yeah it's like
that's my life you know what I mean ooh
I'm so dizzy you have to finish oh come
on yeah I'll do it today bring out Erik
Griffin Erik gums I was like in prison
like if I was in prison would I
I feel like cuz I don't want the
violence of rape I feel like I would be
like all right if you had to go to
prison for life yeah what you wouldn't
just kill yourself I don't think so you
would wait it out you exactly but I
already know that I'd be innocent cuz
I'm I would probably be in prison for
something I didn't do so I would you
know I would hope that there would be a
documentary and stuff you about me I'll
be yeah
you want you want what's that story why
can't I think of the Netflix what's a
cop
Oh with murder yeah making a murder you
want making a murder about which it's a
three yeah
yeah a me an echo yeah I mean what do
you think you got convicted for probably
like human trafficking or something uh
that's actually very plausible yeah
that's pretty possible I feel like
that's a thing I see I was gonna say I'm
not sure yeah I think you could I think
what I think you could show your penis
like you always do in a place where you
shouldn't
and it it's there's like a new a new law
that you're automatically in prison for
life are showing like in Singapore yes
yeah so you could be locked up in
Singapore for doing that but let's say
there's a place in the United States
that has that like Burbank because you
can't even smoke in the streets in
Burbank do you know that's right you
good yeah you get a ticket
yes [ __ ] very [ __ ] not in Van Nuys
you can do whatever the [ __ ] I did
funnier okay that's how hypocritical is
our country that like 18 is such a
number for us but they're states the
United States where it's like 16 and 17
let's do it there's state like Ohio
would that be one well I mean you see
the kind of people that come out of Ohio
for sure no I do need them to watch no I
love people in Ohio you're the best
we love you think we're kidding yeah I
think I there is like four or five
states you go yeah we could we have
computed 16 yes oh really yeah yeah oh
that's amazing
but let's like whoa bartending amazing
not amazing but no it's amazing
information sure no no it's no no it's
information that I did not know okay now
yeah that's why it's amazing what do you
say about bartending I think in
Louisiana or some it's 18 right you can
bartend at 18 well like when I when I
when I was in high school
Wisconsin was still a teen to drink and
I think because people would just go up
there to to go get blasted yeah I know
which is so crazy
also also in Wisconsin this is how this
how Midwest that place is if you are
underage of any age like say you're 15
16 and you're with a parent if the
parent buys you the alcohol that's legal
to drink with a parent in a bar or
restaurant Wisconsin yes it's a state
law